son regard légendaires se déploie
marchât marche sur le presque aussi
célèbre escalier denis papin le monde
connaît cette rue mona lisa sur
l'escalier denis papin ça ça a de la
gueule
121 une marche dédié à l'oeuvre de
léonard de vinci et au savoir-faire
d'une petite imprimerie du loir et cher
derrière ce travail monumental ils sont
cinq ils n'ont pas moins de 210 m²
d'adhésifs à poser et à manier avec
méticulosité un adhésif un peu
particulier puisqu'il est avec un tact
face fort donc il ya une colle un peu
forte
il est conforme à bhl dire qu on le
chauffe et ils épousent la forme de la
terre et limite la filtration d'eau il
faut compter environ 4 à 5 jours de
pause et autant pour la préparation du
matériel dans cet atelier a contre le
visuel est préalablement traitées par un
logiciel afin de le segmenter en
fonction de la longueur et de la hauteur
de chaque marche de marché des
contenants là on a les différentes
planches fait le visuel a été
saucissonné en planches ici
quand on lance l'impression de chaque
planche chacun rouge fait à m 37
delhaize sur 3 mètres de haut et ensuite
c'est découpé sur la table de découpe
la mairie de blois fait appel à cette
imprimerie pour la quatrième fois depuis
2015 coup de chance cette année la météo
clémente les conditions de travail sont
idéales les blésois et les autres
pourront admirer mona lisa jusqu'en
septembre